first of all i wanted to just just say
one thing i'm sitting here with ben
shapiro
i saw ben shapiro when he was a younger
fellow just out of school
and i immediately took to you i said
oh my gosh this is wonderful because i'm
always looking for the righteous
guys you know and i saw him and then i
saw
him i remember when you you took on ucla
when they were out of line when there
was some
andy some pbs stuff yeah the boycott
divestment says yes
exactly and you straighten them out with
what with what what was your weapon
intelligence that you were able to use
your information to glean this
information put it in the right order
and and put it on the table and back
everybody off with the truth
it was amazing amazing thing i think you
can get it on youtube maybe you can get
it on youtube
i think go look at it it was an amazing
moment
and and then i saw you take on more and
more things as
you have grown and i just want to
uh say that
i saw you first no
no but i i'm very grateful for that and
i and and there are so many people
and people that you've encouraged to put
the spotlight on
you know uh we have wonderful
you know warriors for the truth and good
now
uh because of you and your
brothers and sisters who have come forth
so
thank god and you go into the you've
gone into these uh
areas of the universities we're going to
save those kids we've got to change this
we've got to save those kids because
where did the kgb focus
hollywood this is a big thing with lenin
films
the universities and now right down to
the
kindergartens they're being given the
wrong information
you send your kid off to school and they
come back your enemy
very you know we need people to to be
able to
change that so that we children have a
chance
but anyway you guys going into the
universities
with the temper the way it is now and
they're going to throw stuff at you and
they're going to
organize these uh primitive attacks
you know and you go and all you've got
is you're in
your the righteous your your truths
and and this great gift that you have in
law enforcement
and law enforcement lots of lots and
lots of law enforcement exactly
but anyway but you're handling you
you're making statements because those
statements are getting
out not only from that auditorium but
they're
being carried around on youtube and
people are cherishing them and
learning from them so god bless well i
appreciate it's very sweet of you
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
leftist tear gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity
hit the like button